this week on forward author of the new
megatrends seen clearly in the age of
disruption transpoder extraordinaire
marion salzman joins us on forward
it is my pleasure to welcome to ford one
of the most forward-thinking humans on
the planet i i would say
the author of the new mega trend seeing
clearly in the age of disruption marion
salzman marion welcome thanks sandra
thanks for having me
so just to let everyone know i've known
marion for a decade plus uh she helped
launch venture for america back in
2011. we both went to brown university
um and marian's one of those people that
made me feel more
hip and creative uh having gone to brown
she coined the term metrosexual which
impacted us all
i wouldn't say either aspirationally or
otherwise
um but she was was one of the original
trendspotters uh paid handsomely to do
it uh has run some of the biggest pr
firms and efforts uh in the world has
hopscotched globetrotted between here
and
the netherlands and
london
and asia and all parts you can probably
see in the fact that she looks like she
uh you know just got off the plane no
offense
i did i did so it's okay and so it's
fine to tell someone they look tired
when they are it's perfectly cool plus
you and i are old friends i do
wouldn't think much of it um so
uh congrats on the this book what and
like people i think are going to be
fascinated us because everyone wants to
know what's coming next and your book is
largely about uh 2038 which i dare say
is a fine year to home in on
um but i suppose let's start with a
little bit of your origin story how the
heck does one become
a futurist transpotter fortune teller
yeah let's leave the fortune teller
aside because i was really a good
fortune teller i'd be so independently
wealthy i would be telling anyone else's
fortunes i'd be figuring out the stock
market or the crypto pages for myself
but in terms of being a good
trendspotter i think you start off like
being a good nerd
um and why do i say that because
oftentimes you're looking for the
aberrations buried in the quantitative
data what is it that 30 of the people
are doing that it's the 30 percent of
the people that are the next trajectory
not the 30 percent of people that are
lagging behind
and if you think about metrosexual just
as a good example i had seen a statistic
in 2002 that men felt they no longer
were guaranteed to be ceo of the bedroom
or the boardroom the only room they felt
was up for grabs in the house was the
kitchen
um there was another phrase we'd thrown
out there was that um
guys felt that women wanted them to be
just gay enough not looking overwhelming
a majority of men did not agree with any
of those things but a very important 30
to 35 percent did so you look for that
data point
that starts to help you build a
qualitative story and then you're
looking for patterns you're looking for
information
that's out there you're calling the news
in today's world you're calling people's
podcasts you're calling their writings
you're calling their blogs
um you're looking at political reporting
i think i spend more time looking at
political reporting today than i ever
did it's why one of the things that
actually embarrasses me about the book
coming out is i did a very good job in
my humble opinion and i suppose i can
quantify that i did a good job
on dealing with the future crisis that
is coming between taiwan and china and
proof of that is i have a chinese
book publisher who's asked me to remove
a chapter and i have a taiwanese book
publishers asked me to remove a chapter
i did not address
russia
i address strongmen i address the role
of these uh macho men
who um
believe they are not only masters of the
universe but they are controllers of
destiny of their own people and of
people who get in their way
but i did not i didn't see the ukraine
coming for what came i knew that
putin would protect his access to the
sea at any expense
i didn't see him stepping in and
trying to overtake all of the ukraine i
didn't see a folk character like
zielinski rising and almost becoming a
modern-day john f kennedy
i i miss those things so that's one of
the problems
because you're looking for a fact-based
picture
and there's always these random acts
that that come out and and happen so one
of the things that people imagine uh
trendspotters do is they would look for
trendsetters which many people might
think of as young people so do you is
that the case uh like do trends
originate with the young
you know what some trends do and i do
probably spend a disproportionate amount
of my time speaking to people
about
um things that a young person is most
likely to embrace so
the end of the conventional work day the
end of the conventional work place um
the end of conventional currency but no
i don't think they are the only place
where trends get
rewritten i think that
we have to be very careful that for
every age and stage
there is shifts in attitudes beliefs
values and preferences
that ladder into something that that's
really about change
so i guess we'll start there with a
couple of things you just named so the
end of the traditional work day the end
of the traditional workplace
uh now you've been
um kind of cloud-based and itinerant for
years so in a way you've been ahead of
the curve uh i will say that i'll relate
my own experience you might enjoy this
um so i tried to start a company in my
mid-20s we didn't have money for an
office so i was working from home and i
hated it uh because
it was like i tried to start a company
um from home as you know
a 20 something year old i didn't know
anything and i swore to myself it's like
i will never do this again that it next
time i try and start something at a
minimum i'm in the spring for an office
or have a place to go
um so i then worked at a startup then
another startup then became the head of
a company and when was the head
uh
of
education company uh
we had operations all over the country
and even some overseas um but there was
a real office culture uh we would come
in we would do things like and and i
prioritized trying to make that culture
positive uh you know we'd bring in free
food at a certain time and bring people
out to uh events
uh periodically even company trips
uh
and i was someone who believed that that
was an integral part of building a
strong organization a strong team and
getting things uh done and then when i
started venture from america with your
help um it was similar where we had a
really tight office group it was a young
group of young people
now fast forward to today and it seems
that's really kind of passe if i were to
make that argument today a lot of people
would find it very very
jarring
and part of me thinks well that's like
an evolution of who i am in my life
stage because i'm now a 40 something
year old with a family so if me working
remotely or having an interview with you
like this is like perfectly pleasant and
uh you know convenient um but i i do
feel like young people are going to be
missing something not heading into those
traditional office environments even
though if you were to pull those young
people they'd much prefer not to go into
those office environments you know they
might
want to be a hybrid maybe or work from
home
um so but i'm with you that there is no
going back um that this this new
environment is here to stay
um so
uh so first let's go into why you
predict an end to the traditional work
day and workplace and second like what
you think the plus and minuses will be
well first of all i think that young
people are much more transactional i i
know that i'm older than you are and
when i saw work when i graduated from
brown you saw it on a 35-year trajectory
you actually thought about joining a
company you thought you might still be
there 30 odd years later to collect a
gold watch and a going away dinner and
you were quite
mindful of the people who were in the
company that had been there 25 30 35
years and it was something you really
i'm not going to say we're aspirational
for but we're certainly disdainful of
when i speak to a 25 year old about
somebody who might be with an
organization for 35 years
first thing that crosses their mind is
what's the matter with that person
um unless you're talking maybe about
brian moynihan rising through various
permutations of what became bank of
america and become the ceo of bank of
america they'd be like what's the matter
with the dude like why would he do that
um so i think that's one thing that is
quite different
another um is that
we now live in where we're always
connected we're always communicating
with others
so we don't just need that workplace as
a place to feel plugged into the world
you know when i used to go to shy a day
back in the 90s
i needed to go there it was my social
life it was like i went to brown and
then i went to shy day and they made
friends sometimes you even uh dated
people uh or maybe you know if not your
colleagues they're friends
you you your social life was there you
know you you figured out with whom you
were going to have a bagel you figured
out with whom you might play tennis
after work you figured out who you're
going to see a movie with
you argued about a book i mean it
doesn't really matter what your hobby or
pursuit was it gave you this built-in
almost dorm-like life
for as long as you wanted and then once
people
became of sort of a settling down family
age it gave them an outlet to get away
from
those um 30-something duties because
when they came to the office they were
still themselves they were still that
younger at heart person
who could
you know talk nonsense so
work was a very different thing it was
much more holistic it was a source of
comfort and support and all of that
covered changed everything it stripped
away what work was work became a
transaction you pay me x and i do y
i communicate with you through the
screen
we work out the bugs in our screen-based
relationship
we get our work done
in most cases we get our work done
without a lot of the unnecessary
bonding and everything else and i have a
lot more time for myself whether it's
time to pursue my family
time to pursue my uh my
passion projects well well if you if you
say family again for someone like me
it's it's perfectly positive and benign
but like i do feel you know a lot of 20
something year olds aren't at that stage
so
right well i think for those people what
it ended up ended up doing though is is
um
enforcing a sense of loneliness that
they suddenly realized work wasn't
fulfilling wow
so if you were a family person you had
plenty more time to be with that family
that you had chosen
if you were older than that yeah the
same was pretty much true if you were a
single person
you felt very much lost in in place and
so it may it gave you a different set of
priorities
priorities that work was on work is
unlikely to fulfill so i think it's
raised interest in people switching jobs
um give me more money
so so it sounds like one of the so
work relationships become more
transactional and young people in some
ways lower
uh
their
uh
their standards for work in terms of
offering fulfillment because they
wouldn't expect it to offer fulfillment
or or
uh the
center of their social life for example
like that is don't expect that i think
the idea of i live to work
is shot
now i think the idea is i work to live
and so i want the best possible working
situation so that i can live well
if you've been keeping up with me at all
you know that i am very concerned about
the fact that every time we surf the web
on our phone or computer our data is
getting spirited away by big companies
that will just sell our data to the
highest bidder that's not a good time
i'd rather that we are protected and
anonymous online which is why i use
expressvpn what's expressvpn vpn stands
for virtual private network express you
can figure that part out what it does is
it allows you to surf do your thing and
no one is the wiser it's like incognito
mode that actually works i know
incognito mode doesn't do what it says
it's gonna do anyway when your phone
carrier tracks you that's a gross
invasion of your privacy you can either
keep letting them cash in on you or you
can visit expressvpn.com
yang to get the same vpn i use take back
your online privacy today and use my
link to get three extra months free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn dot com slash yang
expressvpn.com yang
protect your data
i think the other thing is it opened up
all new geographic opportunities on the
spectrum for people
so you could have been working in
seattle washington you weren't loving
your life in seattle
you were living in a much more densely
packed housing environment you could
move to boise you could move to
flagstaff
let's have some fun with this so you
just uh named a couple of places that i
think are
experiencing uh
an inflow of uh professionals and uh
remote workers um what are like the
uh towns or cities of the future like
what's gonna be hot boise is definitely
hot from what i hear
uh what what are the other hot towns
so we have to juxtapose this there's two
problems because another trend i really
talk about in the book is climate
migration yeah so if you really want to
be safe you're probably moving to
vermont
there are probably other alternative
places in the midwest although while i
was getting ready to talk to you i was
just reading that there's now booming
fires
um on the kansas border so i guess parts
of the midwest are not as
climate protected but you are absolutely
contemplating maine and vermont
um the places that really picked up the
most number i think of new inhabitants
were
phoenix it was tucson it was austin it
was boise it was all of these second and
third tier southwestern cities
or west or western cities but cities
where you could invent a quality of life
that very much had a strong outdoors
component
because if you had to be socially
distanced you didn't have to be socially
distanced from nature
where there was a strong national parks
culture and where that national parks
culture was essentially
still available to you during most most
of the period of lockdown
i think so three mega trends you cite um
one of them is climate change uh which
uh obviously is not good news um but you
uh project climate migration uh you
project people
uh tuning into weather reports uh in the
same way they would uh
uh virus updates uh because they're
going to be various climate events that
you have to be mindful of
and i think there are certain parts of
the country where that's happening
already
yeah and i think from a long-range
planning standpoint as we put down money
um to own a home whether it's a starter
home or a permanent home
we start to worry about the resell
ability of that home based on mother
nature so you're starting to see even
things like zillow give you climate
scores
for a specific
neighborhood for specific housing so
just like they talk to you about
flooding and walkability
sun scores they're also giving you
climate scores i think we're getting
more and more familiar with the idea
that uh
climate i think what are we up for
temperature points in the last decade
i mean it this is a serious serious
issue and i think
there's a number of things to be worried
about climate is going to factor into
all of the decisions we start to make
and it's not going to be in this
amorphous way that we've all discussed
climate for the last 15 years of like oh
let's go to earth day let's make a
difference let's recycle
um it's going to be a much more serious
and i think that wildfires are something
that we're going to become very very um
aware of attuned to and very frightened
of
yeah they're just going to increase in
in intensity so uh
so between these trends you're citing
of a
transition to a more remote work and
climate change a lot of the projections
are negative
around cities you have a mixed set of
projections around cities
where
cities are both going to be losing a
certain type of person but also gaining
an importance particularly in
places around the world
uh like what do you see as the future of
cities first in the u.s and then it
seems like globally it's a different
story
globally is a different story i think in
the u.s
cities are going to become
communities small communities
neighborhoods for young people i think
we're going to start to be
much more prehistoric as it relates to
what do we want so i want a neighborhood
i want a neighborhood butcher i want a
neighborhood fruit monger i want a
neighborhood
vegetable monger i want
a bookstore
i want a place where i can i can go and
go out of home
and drink coffee i want a neighborhood
park i want to be very close
with a recognition of i want some social
distance i want to be very close to my
neighbors so neighborhoods are getting
you're going to judge your city
much more
based on your neighborhoods i want to be
in bushwick brooklyn new york city
you're not going to say i want to be in
new york city
you're going to want to be in specific
locations where people
um do s
you know have specific more aid i think
as you start to look at
cities outside of the largest
urban cities it's going to change a
little bit because people are going to
be looking based upon quality of the
schools on the quality of the kind of
pods they can create with their
neighbors i think this whole idea of
neighborhood pods we've underestimated
how much they've stuck from
um covid so i not only want to have nice
neighbors but i want to be able to be in
a pod so if i have an emergency i have
somebody i can count on because we've
compromised our nuclear family that
aren't in the same place but by and
large so in exchange we need to farm
these um
what we call lifeboats which are people
that we would
do what we had to do to be able to save
them but we want to be able to be um
in a pod with them
and then i think in the rest of the
world we're looking for 20-minute cities
so cities like seoul korea where you can
get everywhere you need to get to on a
bicycle in 20 minutes and i think we're
going to become very much bike oriented
in cities
i think we're going to be very much
focused on um
taking kids to school on bikes going to
work places on bikes going to do
shopping on bikes going to do
socializing on bikes
and not just the way it's done in
amsterdam where it's done sort of in us
um
everybody does it it's going to be
everybody discovering it because it's
going to be a change
and i think that amsterdam just got
there first where the car is really
you drove a car up to a dinner party
people would think you were a little
ostentatious i think we're going to see
a whole bike families whole bike
families with whole bike helmet families
well are there a lot of people that
would love that image do you see that
happening in the u.s or or just uh
globally
you see it happening in the us but not
in your very very largest cities i see
it happening in places like austin
i see it happening in places like tucson
i see it happening perhaps in places
like des moines i don't see it happening
in places like phoenix where the city
may be stretched out for 75 or 80 miles
we all have our ups and downs and
sometimes it's not clear where to turn
it's one reason i am so proud that this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy i've been a huge believer
in therapy ever since i was a teenager
and got some
you know turns out talking to someone
who's actually trained and licensed
about your problems does a world of good
and now you can do it from the comfort
of your own home in total privacy have
on-demand trained therapists that can
help talk you through whatever it is you
need better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and forward listeners get 10
of their first month at betterhelp.com
yang that's b e t t e r
h e l p dot com slash yang take charge
of your mental health you'll be glad you
did and so will your friends and family
so you travel a lot um do you like
follow people around and just like peer
over their shoulder to see what they're
doing on their phone
okay all right this is gonna make me
sound really scary and now if any of
your listeners see me do this they're
gonna think oh let this woman be around
no i follow them around and look what
they put in their shopping baskets
because i think people have this
incredible
um
disconnect they say they eat healthy and
they put this crap in they say they want
more choice and then they go and they
choose between very few number of items
um they say they want to be experimental
with food items
and they in fact shop off a very mundane
list and it tends to be driven by
coupons um
i i do tend to look at what people put
in their shopping baskets i also tend to
look at what people um sign up for in a
bookstore i i
i'm less interested in kind of where you
go than in how you do it
how you do it parts so
years ago when i used to do really
really awesome and invasive consumer
research i'd go to someone's house i
would do your interview and i'd say
andrew can i offer you an extra hundred
dollars to photograph your garbage
if you've already told me of all the
answers to your family's secrets about x
y or z you probably thought your garbage
was really benign and i would pull out a
hefty bag and i would pull out one of
those sort of kodak instant cameras and
i'd photo and people would have told me
these incredible fantasies about all the
healthy eating they did all the
recycling they did and their garbage
told the truth
so
i i i was actually a pretty good motto
marion your garbage tells the truth
[Laughter]
so the cart going into you we are not
these idealized uh avatars that we're
presenting to the world
and i mean that's look the truth about a
lot of these trends are we wouldn't have
a lot of the problems we had in society
if people were the people they depicted
themselves as
uh yeah i am into that uh so
um i i have to say i agreed with 95 of
the stuff in your your your book um
and
a lot of it was frankly a little bit
challenging in terms of it like it
doesn't paint a rosy uh picture of the
future
um the the three mega trends you cited
were uh the rise of big tech
climate change
uh and kovid
um and it's not necessarily the case
that people are excited about
well and i think you know if you
covet is mental health for me
and this idea that today we talk openly
about our mental health challenges we
feel openly about our mental health
challenges
that mental health is
raging around us
um
qualitatively i can prove it to you
quantitatively i haven't attempted it
but it feels to me like every time i
turn around i open the paper i open up a
major news magazine and i read about a
suicide of someone i thought was
mentally healthy
and i think that we're having a great
deal of people feeling very lost i mean
the rules don't work anymore so to me
covered the virus
is something
but what kobe did to us it it not
our a game
yeah i think you there's a quote in your
book it says something around chaos the
new normal uh and that people feel that
because of coded well i noticed
something i didn't catch coven until
about five weeks ago
and the whole time i didn't catch cove
but i sat around waiting for it
and so you're completely
upended
waiting for something terrible to happen
then when it happens i mean in my case i
had already been
vaccinated and boosted
it really wasn't so terrible but what
was terrible was the nerve wracking time
going all the way back to world economic
forum davos
over two years ago when i first thought
i'd been exposed
to cover the number of times when you
feel like oh my god my life is going to
be over and i think that people feel
that way i think right now you have
people feeling that way about the war in
the ukraine
about what's going to happen with nato
and europe
about the risk of
a world war iii in this country i mean i
don't know if you noticed the last
couple of weeks but there's been
journalists qualified credible
journalists journalists that we would
read who are speculating about when the
civil war in the u.s when it starts
where is it going to start is it going
to start in michigan is it going to
start in new york state
we're reading this stuff and it's no
wonder we can't
find any
calm
and so we assume chaos and we project
chaos and we bring chaos in there
oh uh i i know exactly the journalists
you're talking about uh because this is
uh
something i'm focused on which is the
the potential for political conflict in
the united states which which i think is
a very real possibility so i can see why
folks are digging in i've actually
interviewed a couple of the authors
you're talking about who wrote the books
that then inspired those pieces
and i think it it
speaks to something you're identifying
right now which is that covid has
isolated us from each other um it's made
people stressed out and ornery and
negative
uh and then when you present uh like a
positive wholesome unifying message to
folks i think it just
falls on deafer ears than than
ordinarily and then if you have like a
negative
granted transactional message people are
somewhat more receptive or
people will just shrug and say well at
this point um you know i'm not going to
bother i'm not going to stick my neck
out um
in a way that might
um
prevent a problem from getting worse
because let me just uh take care of the
folks in my lifeboat um you know like
that that i think that's a very real
sense and so if you project
forward uh it's it's very uh
deeply deeply concerning i i think it's
at this point rational to be deeply
concerned
i think it's actually
um bubble living to assume that we are
not at the brink of the potential of a
civil war in this country i felt that
way
before i really started on this book
before i really understood the
seriousness of covid because i felt that
for the first time we couldn't argue
rationally with one another we couldn't
we had lost our sportsmanlike ability to
agree to disagree
and i know that in watching the hearings
the last couple of weeks both january 6
hearings
the hearings on justice
on the new justice for the supreme court
i felt like what happened
i mean you know most of us still grew up
with grandmothers who told us that if we
didn't have something nice to say say
nothing at all
and we've lost that
the worst in political culture because
they're just uh posturing for cable news
they're like hey let me see if i can get
a viral moment or social media actually
i mean you know it's like oh if i have a
video that uh gets a million likes then
you know then that's gonna be a huge win
for me so
like uh you know the civil thing to do
would just be to ask legitimate
questions about your judicial philosophy
but like that's not going to score any
points so let me get out there and see
if i can make some headlines over you
know
that was i mean i think that was my net
takeaway was i agree with very very very
little that liz cheney has done in her
career but i couldn't be more proud of
the way she projects herself as a person
with respect but i realize she gets
absolutely no credit for simply being
polite and reasonable
and you realize that there's this strain
of people marion and like this group so
liz cheney is a like a perfect example
but there's like a
a group of principled uh polite uh
republicans that that are just uh
getting pillory it's like an endangered
species you know i think that the number
of uh
representatives that voted to impeach
trump uh on principle
uh you know it's like now half of them
are either uh already uh out
out or being censured or being uh you
know it's like that like that
uh that strain of republicanism is now
very much an endangered species and it's
tough
well and the same i think the same
thing's happening on the democratic side
and i think that they all get named to
the front line because then there's
going to be someone who's very very
much on the left that's going to run
against them but
the bigger problem is i think we've lost
our capacity for consensus
and for um
negotiating polite deal making and i
think that's the thing that makes me
feel very
uncomfortable
i think another thing i touch on the
book is inequities and
look i don't know the most extreme
income inequality the winner take all
economy
i mean i don't know how we explain as
humans jeff bezos mackenzie's got it's
like you have these two polar opposite
humans who are approaching the world
change and betterment and i'm not going
to minimize
does jeff bezos have an objective of
a positive change but you look at what
she's out there doing and you realize
that one person with a great deal of
money can actually change an industry
like philanthropy yeah it's tremendous
and you start to realize um
even she's subject to criticism
even someone who is giving away money
without an agenda
i mean unlike
um let's say a gates foundation or a
bloomberg
where it comes with and maybe it should
i'm not telling you it shouldn't it
comes with a whole set of program ideals
and program management strategies and
all that
we we can't we have this problem
accepting goodness in others
we are so
suspect
um there's a lot of mistrust a lot of
yes there's mistrust everywhere on
everything and i think that that really
it's going to impact the
current generation of children
it's going to impact the next generation
of elected officials
um
[Music]
it's going to separate this country i
mean
i saw yesterday over lunch i went to
listen to the the newest governor
of new york and you listen to her talk
about her point of view on abortion you
realize that she's going to keep the
state wide open
and you realize that this is going to
lead to a great deal of mistrust
from states on the other side of the
issue and and that we've never come to a
consensus
we
are just each fighting
to protect what we believe to be
true and fair and and
frankly um
[Music]
the inequities where is the money where
is the power
where is all those things it's really
gotten lost in in a lot of noise
yeah that it it's i i think you just
coined a new term marian this can be
your your new term
transaction
transactional america
i need to get rid of metrosexual so i'm
desperate for one so that's okay as
actually but no but i think that's
i think that's what's arriving at our
doorstep uh you know you you make broad
appeals and then people will be like oh
yeah yeah but like you know
like what's in it what's in it for me
really
let's talk turkey you can like make
appeals to values all day long but you
know it's like i
uh like i i want uh cash in hand i want
something that that's going to
be something i can take home to my
lifeboat
and to the people in my life but right
and and this whole idea
that we haven't gotten comfortable with
about multicultural
a multicultural lifeboat a multicultural
country i i find it incredulous that
people weren't expecting this
we've known it for 20 years
i mean i recall in 1998 in in in the
book next we wrote about it and i did
get my wrist slap because i sort of said
by you know the end of this century i'm
sorry of this decade
um the country wouldn't be white the
country wouldn't be english speaking
and the country um
would be very much a blended and blurred
society and that's exactly where we've
ended up and it's wonderful and instead
of embracing it for all of its richness
and robustness
we've decided to go back into our
corners and fight about it and
well this is a very consistent theme of
the people who are concerned about
political violence is that apparently
the pattern in other societies is if you
have a group
uh that's concerned about a loss of
status then they tend to uh respond
very very poorly sometimes aggressively
and even violently
um and so i think people like
you who've looked at the
the uh changing composition of america
and think okay like we're going to head
towards like a
benign uh mixed
uh
group and perception of what america is
um like there's actually this this
reaction and it's something that you
know i drew criticism um for for when i
was running for president is that i
tended to
um make an economic case i was like look
we're we're gutting these manufacturing
jobs we're getting all these jobs like
you know like that that's the problem
and it is interrelated like we are
uh hollowing out the middle class um
and that there are a lot of
uh
uh white people in that middle class and
then look up and are like why is this
happening and then uh you know they get
presented terrible leadership and
terrible arguments like oh it's someone
else's fault and um you know like my
argument is like look it's not these
other people's fault it's if it's
anyone's fault it's the robot's fault or
it's the the
economic system's fault
but yeah but that's but that's not going
to be a popular political case like the
the pattern in other societies is
uh blame another group uh and then that
that will hasten a rise to power well i
mean if you think about it from a
standpoint of i go to 2038 because
there's a y2k 2038 linkage where we're
going to have a software glitch a clock
glitch in 2038 that will be a little bit
like y2k we'll probably get it solved
because we'll put the horsepower behind
that we need to solve it but you know
you have a 2024 problem which what is
that election going to bring us oh my
gosh yeah i'm so focused on this period
i think that all the time and i i i mean
it's funny because going to this
eleanor's legacy luncheon yesterday i
sat back and looked and i realized new
york has nothing in common with america
i mean in new york you already have a
primarily female black city council i
believe
it's i think majority
i think it was majority people exactly
you have
a
black american woman
aeg you have
a female governor
you have a number of things and it's so
far people are not resisting all those
issues of intersectionality that would
normally keep people very busy in other
places
um but you know we have to ask ourselves
what is this going to mean because
the intersectionality
is something that people really fight
against i mean
you know 40 years ago
or even even 20 years ago but if you
think about the book i really started it
as of 2000 in the year 2000 it wasn't
even cool to be a woman
we thought it was we thought we had
options open to us but we still there
was still some real question about
whether our voices could be heard
i would argue that that is mostly a
thing of the past
but you see the exact same thing
happening to your black female
counterpart
you certainly see it happening to your
asian female counterpart i'm not sure an
asian man or a black man has gotten his
full rights extended to me
we have such a long way to go and it
seems to happen at snails pace in this
country so this intersection so this
the problems of prejudice the problems
we're going to have to redefine a script
for a way to live a modern life in a on
a planet that is much more challenged
than it was 20 years ago let alone 40
years ago let alone 60 years ago
and it's not going to be easy
yeah that that is definitely the picture
you paint in the book um one thing i
enjoyed about your projection of the
future is that small is the new big and
that like and having a little slice of
nature is going to be
uh something that we seek uh and and
value highly and i have to say that was
a fairly benign
picture it's like oh you know like i i
kind of like the idea of having people
having their uh little little hidey
holes and uh you know being able to go
for nature walks
i think green grass and clean air are
going to become a priority for people
it's really the anecdote to all these
other
climate issues it's also an antidote to
the pace
of the chaos in modern cities
and i think that we need to be very very
conscious of the fact that people need a
place to escape to and that nature does
good things for people especially given
that people are need a chance to reset
i mean they need a chance to reboot
themselves every now and then otherwise
right now it's like going down the
interstate at 80 miles an hour having a
flat tire and changing the flat tire
while you keep driving
yeah and doing it and doing it via zoom
um so so you talk about the two great
powers the us and china you suggest that
neither of them is necessarily going to
lead to the world that you you'd want
that that there's not uh necessarily
going to be an american-led world order
that we're excited about or uh china-led
world order uh certainly that people
would be positive about uh and then
um you cite the rise of big tech and
surveillance i think this is going to be
a
a bigger and bigger deal particularly
now when folks are concerned about uh
crime and uh public safety and then one
of the potential tools is um
surveillance and ai uh face
uh recognition and then in the states
people like no no no we can't use that
stuff um and then you're like well in
china they use that stuff up the wazoo
and everyone shrugs
um and that that's obviously two very
very different approaches but i feel
like uh it's going to become a hotter
and hotter issue here in the states
yeah and i think for years a certain
percentage of our population traded off
and thrived under an aura of anonymity
they were just an everyday every way
person who went around about living
their life and they didn't ask a lot of
questions they didn't make a lot of
demands on government or on their
neighbors they kind of and they just
stayed off the map
and i think now the map gets everybody
and the map gets you when you make a
little mistake or a big mistake
so
i think that
this lack of privacy
you know it's funny because it goes back
20 years or so that people began to
worry about privacy
but at this point well what's funny
marion is i think people are
divulging data or having it frankly just
uh hoovered up into the cloud from the
megatech companies all the time
um
and we're cool with amazon and google
knowing everything about us um but then
if if it's a public actor then you're
like oh no like you know like i don't
trust the government to do anything with
this stuff because there's this big
brother orwellian aspect it is funny i
think we trust companies more than we
trust our government by a significant
degree
there is actually there is actual
quantitative data that supports that
statement i mean i've been looking at
that recently and it sort of scares me
like why do you assume
especially with facebook that your data
is safer with facebook than with the irs
well facebook's use of our data is uh
part of one of the trends you cite
around mental health i feel like it's
making us sick uh you know so but it
seems like we're more accepting of a
private company making us and our kids
sick than we are of
uh you know the government
having the you know like that that same
access
yeah now look i mean one of the things i
didn't really dig into the book and i i
probably will dig in in a follow-up
article is the insta meltdowns but if
you think about this i mean instagram
can literally cause
a teenage girl to melt down in a way
that you
it wasn't really possible to be
demoralized
by several thousand people when i was
growing up if you really really got
that's actually a very profound
observation marian it wasn't possible to
be demoralized
simultaneously by several thousand
people when either of us were growing up
i could not agree more i mean it it it's
if it there is a certain truth that you
your naysayers and your accolades
were all a manageable number of people
kind of work your way through
you know i graduated like a manageable
number of people like you could count
about one hand it's like two people are
like go marry it and then two people
like you stink and you're like yeah okay
whatever but i mean you know when these
things happen
and now you're starting to see the law
step in so when if
a very unpleasant example is if
one horrendous teenager in an outburst
to another says i want you dead
and the kid goes off and kills himself
um there is liability and accountability
and so it's the mental health thing
it's the size of the megaphone that the
social
universe has provided us
it's the degree to which you can harness
the power of the metaverse or any of
those systems it's the
geometric way that this news can spread
and it's also um
i think this the danger you know when
everything
is already feels dangerous
there is almost an energetic pull to
something more dangerous
wow that's that's very good so as you
get closer and closer to it
um i think you feel good about it i mean
these are all terrible terrible
observations that i wish i didn't think
were true
but it's just so
thoroughly different than growing up
in the 80s or the 90s or even the oos
where
oh i mean i'm an 80s 90s kid myself i'm
a jedi
it's like you know you you would just
the world had you on a much tighter
leash and magnitudes of scale were tiny
um
the other thing was you didn't have you
didn't have the pounding of breaking
news at all points
oh yeah i you know someone said to me
marion you'll appreciate this but but
she said that um that it's up to gen x
to fix
uh big tech because we remember the
times before and after
uh you know like i i remember the times
before and i'm so glad frankly it didn't
exist
i was growing up and and you know then
and what's funny too i'll just speak for
myself on this like i was running an
education company and i was directed uh
directing services towards young people
and so you know like i was like okay
facebook gotta get on that like uh
twitter twitter so twitter i got on
because i ran for president uh linkedin
i had but like you know i i kind of um
you were probably the same way did you
feel pressured to use these things
because you're like oh i work with young
people all the time like i have to see
what they're doing so i had the
exclusive rights to do online market
research on aol going back to around
1993. so i felt obliged to be on there
because it was the way i could figure
out what young people were saying and
especially young adults were saying for
me it was my a little bit less teens
a little bit more 20 somethings like you
would do your annual surveys
for let's say the esquire sex survey the
glamour sex survey
your celebrity service people would tell
you things they wouldn't tell you
looking you in the eye
if you were talking to them via tech
but even then i knew
there was a stranger danger to it
um and but it was much less than it is
today
back then i used to argue about one in
35 people didn't have the right
intentions
and we knew things like so we would mail
because we were paying people to be part
of research we knew their social
security numbers we knew their addresses
to mail them checks
and we still knew that about 135 were a
problem
i think in today's world
and first of all you might have 35
identities maybe only one of your
identities is the problem but that
problem but that identity is a big
problem people didn't do things like
that in the beginning with social media
they had an identity it was probably
your name or something
the world has changed so completely so
dramatically i like i've become and this
is not an addiction i'm very proud of i
become addicted to this 90-day fiance
show
which is like these people that meet
people they fall in love with through
mostly through online services and they
try to bring them to the us under k-1
visas and you're watching this and
you're like
where did you find each other
and you realize that there are people
that spend hours days weeks months
online
out of sheer loneliness and i don't
think we understand how lonely people
are i mean and that is a point within
the mental health thing is the point
within the lifeboat thing it's a point
in the thing about things getting
smaller when communities get smaller you
need to have more intimate ties if you
don't have more intimate ties you are
more lonely so so the the loneliness you
you speak of so there are some trends
that are very clear now in the data that
i think are going to become more extreme
um around young people having less sex
uh and
um
and then getting married less uh and uh
i think that both of them are gonna
continue it reminds me a little bit of
what happened in japan
decades ago where they also uh you know
stopped marrying and having sex
um you could see a number of reasons for
it but i can see that happening pretty
clearly especially in a time when
you know we're doing all this stuff
remotely and people i know young people
who
uh are just
logging in and lying down and chilling
and i'm just like you know shouldn't you
be out there
trying to date someone
[Laughter]
um so but but i do think it's a new
normal where they just like shrug and be
like yeah and then you know like uh like
like
and for whatever reason i think a lot of
people
have not necessarily
um
uh
believe that that's in the cards for
that um whether it's because of uh their
um financial prospects uh or you know
like even their native desires one of
one of the things that i i see is that
people dislike friction
um and relationships are filled with
friction you know i mean i i'm i'm
married
it's like
you know
one of my jokes would like someone i you
know directs me in like an environment
um and then they're like oh sorry and
i'm like i can take direction i'm
married
like of course
um and i feel like a lot of young people
too
um to today it's like that you know they
just kind of live the way they want to
live and that if someone um like manages
to be a part of that then
that's fine but like it's almost never
the case that someone's just gonna
completely be a part of the way you're
living without some adjustment
no i think you're right i mean in the
book i do deal quite a bit with what
happens um it with the alone
the aloneness concept in japan i mean
the whole idea that today it's perfectly
acceptable to go to a japanese
restaurant alone
20 years ago you would have been treated
like an absolute pariah i don't even
think you would have been served
the idea that japanese elders are living
completely alone 20 years ago
extended family would have found some
place to store you whether you were a
parent an aunt or an uncle they would
have just moved you in and made you part
of
that sort of high-rise lifeboat
and i i think that things have just
changed so much and we haven't
caught up to i do think you're
absolutely right
also that young people
are much more gender ambiguous
and so they're not even sure exactly
what they want
and in playing that out
it both widens but narrows choices
and i think that it also leaves them
very very frustrated they're not going
to find the exact
yang to the yin that they're looking for
and i i pun intended or not i said that
i was like oh no no but i mean i i
really do think that it's like
it's it's a much tougher
world
um and
there may not be the same motivation
because i think there's a lot less
interest maybe in having children
yes well that's in the numbers too
obviously certainly in having a large i
mean i remember the very beginning of
kobe
having a pretty strong argument with a
sociologist that i was interviewing for
the book who said to me oh this is going
to be the great baby boom and i'm like
only for the exceedingly wealthy
everyone else is going to be absolutely
scared to death
and we've seen that that's absolutely
what happened for a tiny tiny group of
extremely wealthy people
there was a small boom and for everybody
else it was like
i don't even know if i want the
responsibility of bringing children into
this world well um
dating and then getting married and then
having children are all very much acts
of sustained optimism you know what i
mean and so like if if you
uh introduce a lot of uncertainty i
think all those things go down
personally yeah i think look i tried to
make the book as hopeful as possible
in a world where
there
there certainly is hope
but i think you have to start by hoping
inside you
and then hoping um with a small cluster
of people with whom you share attitudes
and beliefs
and then i think you have to hope very
fervently for your community and then
for the broader american community and
now i think sadly for
the world interestingly enough in our
apartment in switzerland i have um
which just chose
i have a ukrainian family ukrainian
refugee family living with us
wow and i wanted it i wanted to just do
it straight away when the opportunity
came up
i went to a
harvard student website and i just
signed up
and
actually it's the most hopeful thing
i've done probably in a decade because
here are these people who somehow
managed to get from the ukraine
to lausanne switzerland and they
managed to do it
not by talking about it
but by literally packing their immediate
family and their cat
into a car
and traveling
you know the
18 hours or something and you start to
realize there are some people that just
live with hope eternal
and they were gonna make a life for
their family no matter what it took
and
i've gotten to know quite a bit quite a
number of ukrainian refugees
through this site because we're
bombarded still daily with you have any
more rooms and
it's really interesting because that's
the most hopeful place i've seen on the
planet and so there's something to be
said for the way that zielinski talks to
his followers that he gives them of
something to believe in
even though if you sat back rationally
and tried to put mathematical odds to
what he's saying and doing
you'd be like this is hopeless well he's
increasing the odds single-handedly
uh and it it does uplift one when you
think about
you know
uh
the the fact that so many people like
you are trying to help uh get ukrainians
and ukrainians themselves showing so
much
uh fortitude and courage
uh
yeah but we can all only help one to one
i think for me that was the lesson on
like i was tired of listening to all my
posh friends talk about helping by
sending checks for five grand i was like
you know what i just saw on tv these
three harvard students had set up this
website to match ukrainians that needed
a place family we have a three-bedroom
apartment in switzerland we don't use it
that frequently i'm there right now i'm
here to welcome the people i'm going to
put myself on the website and and people
were like you're completely crazy all i
asked for was proof that they had a
passport from anywhere in the world
you're not crazy at all like i i think
that's the greatest like
my comment was like what are they gonna
do steal my converse sneakers like i
should worry
these people have been driven out of
switzerland there's nothing in the world
i have that they're not welcome to i
give them what anything they can find
that they want in the apartment take it
it's not stealing i'm just giving it to
you but it was interesting to watch
because i think that
we we're gonna need to relearn
generosity and it goes back to the you
know it goes back i suppose it's a
biblical statement i always associate
with john f kennedy but i think i'm
wrong that for whom a great deal has
been given a great deal is expected i
don't know that that has resonated right
now it's like if you've been given
unfortunately even people that have
right now are feel uh bleedered and
under siege uh and and in that
environment that people are less likely
to be generous i have seen counter
examples of that you're one uh there's a
gentleman i know who brought in a family
from
uh afghanistan um you know like uh
during the uh taliban takeover just like
you know there there were folks who
worked with american government and he
has them in his house right now
um in the states um but uh there are a
lot of people who right now are
hunkering down in a time when we kind of
need people to open up
yeah no no i mean it's like it's funny i
didn't even tell my husband what i was
doing he was in the us i wasn't slipping
someone's like dude i called him i'm
like by the way did you know that we
have four afghan we have four ukrainians
moving he goes it was perfect it was
obviously you could tell it's used to me
he's like what do they eat
that's kind well i actually did think to
myself what are they going to eat on
like an ongoing basis and you know it's
like no no no no
i said don't worry i said don't worry i
ordered a lot of grain and a lot of
vegetables and they appear to make a lot
of soups and it was just so funny
because he knew better than to argue
with me on this not that he would have
but even if it ever crossed his mind he
knew to choose a i just transitioned to
something practical top line of like
it's good work that's good partnership
have you got have you gotten them food
i'm like don't worry i've taken care of
greens and vegetables but it was you
know like i just think that we
this book is coming out it's coming out
at a time
when never in my rec look i can remember
the late 70s when you had odd and even
gas and you had jimmy carter i guess is
president
and
the world seemed terrible but i was so
young i can't really remember
the responsibility that came with it
i can't remember another time when i
think the world felt so vulnerable i
certainly don't remember a time when we
did this much talking about nuclear
warfare
i don't remember any time where
polarization
was as profound as it is today and where
we couldn't even be polite
to one another and agree to disagree and
be sportsmanlike and if these things
don't change
i don't know that we have a happy ending
i think there's an enormous pressure on
the 24 and the 28 elections
um i i think that's probably the great
pressure in the u.s i think
we saw what happened in france over the
weekend we know what the runoff is going
to be um
my guess is macron
because they'll pull it off yeah
but that tells you something because i
mean i remember years ago when it was
her father le pen running
it wasn't this kind of variable
yeah i i'm i'm deeply concerned about
the 24 race in particular i'm going to
be doing everything i can to be helpful
um
and
hopefully help see us through a really
tough time
uh now it's going to be a massive
challenge i i do think that some things
are going to be on the table that are
uh
relatively new or haven't been seen in
american politics for quite some time
um we shall see but i i do feel like if
we just let nature take its course it
might not take its course in a way
people are excited about uh and
i've discovered a group of people who
are very like-minded who are like yeah
yeah like we we kind of need to do
something
that like this is not like a business as
usual situation
yeah and then and it can't be business
as usual because the world is in
business as usual given the degree to
which the the
planet earth is deteriorating given the
degree to which
inequities are
mounting there's just certain things
that can't be allowed
to
happen unsupervised
yeah and i think that if i had a point
of the book i started off and i said it
wasn't going to be a political book
i really had to go back in and do a
complete rewrite so it didn't become a
political book yeah it's not a political
book it became a book about i mean it's
that took an awful lot of work because
it's too easy
to blame everything wrong
on a single administration or on a
dosage of administrations and that's not
what has has happened what's happened is
from 20 from the year 2000 to the year
2020 the world changed entirely
we didn't catch up to it the virus
caught us off guard the virus put into
spotlight
all those things we're living with and
now we have got to have a plan going
forward that people can live with they
can respect and most importantly they
can respect themselves so that they
respect others because i think the loss
of self-respect is not an insignificant
problem either
yeah there's a lot a lot a lack of uh
self-esteem and confident like genuine
self-esteem not this kind of false uh
bravado um but like a deep sense of
belief
uh well
you're a woman after my own heart and
you see the future more clearly than
just about anyone uh congratulations on
this book the new mega trend seen
clearly in the age of disruption uh do
you have any conclusory notes for us to
give people
a sense of of hope and uh optimism and
what it was going to be a challenging
time i mean your book lays that out i
certainly think that's the case but
there are still
uh still strains of uh of uh things to
be excited about
yeah i mean to me the most important
thing is every day to do one positive
act for a better future
i mean if you live i love it every day
you just sort of do something i don't
care whether it's read a book and then
donate a book to a neighborhood library
i don't care whether it's
walk the grocery store instead of drive
i don't care if it's eating all
vegetable dinner instead of
to me
what you do is less important that you
put into your head i am going to admit
do one act every day to a more positive
future
well if everyone listening to this does
that then uh we'll be on our way and
from my experience doing that one
positive thing actually does make you
feel a lot better it's one reason why i
try and act positively because uh it
helps my my state of mind uh marion
thank you so much uh you're you're
you're a dear friend you make us all a
bit wiser and more keyed into what's
coming i appreciate you so much thank
you thanks for having me guys bye
you